>> Tucker: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
HURRICANE IAN AS WE'VE TOLD YOU
HAS CRUSHED THE STATE OF
FLORIDA, MORE THAN A MILLION
PEOPLE HAVE NO POWER.
THIS IS A CATASTROPHE.
IT'S A NATIONAL DISASTER.
PEOPLE WILL CERTAINLY BE KILLED
BECAUSE OF IT.
UNDER CIRCUMSTANCES LIKE THAT,
DECENT PEOPLE PUT POLITICS ASIDE
FOR A MOMENT, BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GHOULS.
THEY REALIZES SOME THINGS, LIKE
LIFE AND DEATH, ARE IMPORTANT
THAN POLITICS.
THEY DON'T GIVE POLITICAL
SERMONS AT FUNERALS, FOR
EXAMPLE, BUT AT MSNBC THERE'S NO
REASON TO ABIDE BY DECENCY.
CLAIRE McCASKILL DELIVERED A
SERMON, AND IT WAS ABOUT "STOP
COMPLAINING ABOUT JOE BIDEN."
>> I HOPE THOSE THAT HIT AT THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT, REMEMBER
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT IS
THERE FOR THEM AT A TIME OF
DISASTER.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: CAN YOU IMAGINE?
NO DECENCY.
NO SHAME.
NONE OF THEM HAVE DECENCY OR
SHAME.
ONE TRIED TO LINK IT TO CLIMATE
CHANGE.
HIS GUEST SHUT HIM DOWN.
JAMIE ROMAN KNOWS WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT, DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL OCEANIC AND ATMOSPHERIC
ADMINISTRATION.
WATCH THIS EXCHANGE.
>> CAN YOU TELL WHAT THIS IS,
WHAT EFFECT CLIMATE CHANGE HAS
ON THIS PHENOMENON?
>> WE CAN TALK ABOUT CLIMATE
CHANGE AT A LATER TIME.
I WANT TO FOCUS ON HERE AND NOW.
>> WHAT EFFECT DOES CLIMATE
CHANGE HAVE ON THIS PHENOMENON
THAT'S HAPPENING RIGHT NOW?
SEEMS THE STORMS ARE
INTENSIFYING.
THAT'S THE QUESTION.
>> YOU CAN'T CONNECT IT TO ANY
ONE EVENT.
>> LISTEN, I GREW UP THERE.
THESE STORMS ARE INTENSIFYING.
SOMETHING IS CAUSING THEM TO
INTENSIFY.
>> Tucker: HOW CAN I HELP THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN THE MIDDLE
OF A DISASTER?
MOST PEOPLE TONIGHT THINK THAT.
AMY KLOBUCHAR ANNOUNCED IF WE
GAVE HER MORE POWER, HURRICANES
WOULDN'T HAPPEN, BECAUSE TURNS
OUT THEY CONTROL THE WEATHER, IF
YOU VOTE FOR THEM.
>> WE HAVE TO WIN AS THIS
HURRICANE BEARS DOWN ON FLORIDA,
WE HAVE TO WIN IN THE MIDTERMS.
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT SOMEONE
YOU WOULD HIRE AS YOUR EXECUTIVE
ASSISTANT, BECAUSE SHE'S TOO
INCOMPETENT.
NO ONE WANTS TO WORK FOR HER,
BECAUSE SHE SCREAMS AT HER
STAFF.
YET THAT PERSON IS CLAIMING
SUPERNATURAL POWERS, SAYING THIS
AS PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY DYING.
WE CALLED AMY KLOBUCHAR'S OFFICE
TODAY AND ASKED HER TO COME ON
TO EXPLAIN HOW SPECIFICALLY THEY
WOULD HAVE TAKEN CONTROL OF THE
WEATHER AND PREVENTED HURRICANE
IAN.
HOW WOULD YOU HAVE DONE IT?
HERE'S FULL POWER.
FULL FUNDING, AMY KLOBUCHAR,
TELL US HOW YOU WOULD STOP THE
HURRICANE.
REALLY, SHE WOULDN'T STOPPED.
SHE'S ALWAYS WELCOME